hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to what
happens when you make a successful
website anniversary special make an even
bigger one the next year make an even
bigger one the next year and then make
the biggest most viewed and most
expensive one that they've ever made you
say fuck you I'm tired and would rather
have other people contribute to the fact
I have nothing to offer these are their
table scraps sort of like a creep show
meets Twilight Zone meets the guy
begging for money outside the uncanny
valley is the fifth anniversary special
of that guy with the glasses calm which
I know would make you think that I would
have to enjoy it and give it a positive
review well I would if I was fucking it
I'm not instead we have new character
it's been introduced to the audience
because quite clearly that made also
well in the past so let's take a look at
anniversary special they clearly need
more of yours truly this is the uncanny
valley the special opens with what looks
like is going to be a blackface routine
but instead gives us something even more
creepy a Rob Zombie puppet made out of
human flesh join me as we travel to
another dimension actually this is the
webmaster who is supposed to be kind of
like the Cryptkeeper from Tales from the
Crypt
except strangely enough that lifeless
animatronics somehow looks more
convincing than this guy I'm not sure
how they did that who are you
um I'm Thomas he comes across a guy who
got double-booked in the studio they
were supposed to perform in and hijinks
listen veggie burger the station said I
had this studio till 8:00
this gracious me they must have
double-booked can you get out of here
now not before I balance the chakras the
who fast forward with it that's what I
want to know nothing I just wanted to
have to can couple Oba this leads to our
first story called dragon boy we open
with a guy named Karl it's supposed to
be an obsessed gamer but clearly isn't
because I can't smell him through the
screen as his coworker calls him up to
make sure he's getting his report ready
for work
you got the merger proposal covered oh
yeah nearly done why don't you finish it
I will I just got to get this one
dungeon
what are you playing sky guard do this
at a game that's a lifestyle choice as
the supported black friend in every
movie ever made it is my job to yell at
you and be as paranoid as possible of
course the supportive black friend in
every movie ever made can only be
outdone by the support of hot girlfriend
and every movie ever made though to be
fair she doesn't support him as much as
tell him he should stop playing his
stupid game and do chores around the
house you know because this is a
constant problem for most obsessed
gamers when their incredibly hot
girlfriends who don't have an
interesting gaming interrupts their
playing before working on a business
merger that could make their successful
company even more money all while being
clean-shaven wearing a business shirt at
home and being relatively clean and good
looking for someone who clearly has an
addiction - I'm not buying it either and
don't get me wrong I'm not saying that
all gamers are like this I'm saying that
clearly for the addiction that this
character is supposed to have only a
truly obsessed addicted gamer would
think they really have a life like this
in fact we actually have an artist
rendition of what the typical obsessed
gamer looks like the being way too nice
but Karl is still unsatisfied with his
life and which is it could be more like
the video game world what happened to my
freedom what happened to adventure
sometimes I wish life for more like you
sky guard well if there's anything the
incredible mr. limpet has taught us is
that your bad wish will love to make for
a bad movie and sure enough the game
spits out his online creation named
improv and now he has to adapt to all
world yoyo idiots made the game so do
you know what's gonna happen okay I'm
sorry could you put that down please
thank you know you're not gonna win the
Nobel Prize you know can the trailers
for these plots we've heard a million
times be reduced down to a single
lettered category it would just make the
cliches go faster he was a um B but he
didn't oh hey
but suddenly uh um let's go with C and
now they all right C again channel
awesome presents oh come on I can think
of a better title than those and of
course insert fish-out-of-water
misunderstandings here on evany coffin
preserves winter for food here what is
this enchanted altar what sort of plant
does not need water so this mystical
portal chairs and our peoples adventures
what is this thing in front of me oh
it's my hand watch crafts and trust me
if that doesn't do it for you then
you're in for a whole world of hurt
this film is like a retelling of Thor
except all the kind of enjoyable moments
that we're in there are now replaced
with just the kat dennings scenes you
have been warned so Carl rather than
deal with the problem decides to just go
to bed and hope that everything takes
care of itself
the first believable act of an obsessed
gamer I've seen all movie morning who is
she the next morning he sees that yen
brought has abducted a kid thinking that
he has saved her from a monster that was
really just a school bus that's a school
bus you idiot
her sweet treats an eight or stole her
Stan you know when the enchanted magical
realm of sky garden fixes wake a little
better is that my hard cider
that's okay mister we were gonna have a
test today
anyway yeah oh my god she's drunk no you
have to get out now this guy I love this
guy man is probably the only performance
I can believe in this picture if I was a
kid on set I know I'd want a drink
what is this are you working for Castle
Grayskull now his girlfriend of course
finds out it is immediately drawn to him
brush shivery
or maybe she just thinks he's weird out
doing a lawyer rings barity either way
he's took out more manhood the imitation
jewfro over here oh crap I gotta go I'm
gonna be late so he tells Jessica to
keep him at home but she loses him when
she has to head out to a job that is
never really described make you chillin
thal stand-in he of course follows Karl
to work and as is common with these
setups blends in just fine through
convenient misunderstandings even
flipping the boss over doesn't seem to
upset anybody sorry he flipped you and I
took it like a black Chuck Norris we're
men this is what we do he gave me a
challenge we fought Lisa put muffled HR
now if you'll excuse me I'm going to
visit a man in prison who tried to
assassinate me and make him
vice-president of the company
Ian bras brought in to motivate the
other workers which naturally pisses
Carl off almost as much as the fact that
you're broth is doing better at looking
after his hit girlfriend
oh he comes from a world where this is
considered charming and not creepy
last time I snuck into a woman's room
and watched her sleep let's just say it
really was the last time things are even
worse when she's awake as it looks like
he's moved on from creepy stalking to
gift-giving oh come on it's one thing to
pose like you're in a porn for woman's
calendar but this time you know what
you're doing when I entered the tool as
feds found out I fought the ghost of a
mystic dragon in his ribs
there was this pendant of incredible
beauty I give it to you Wow I should use
that story every time I buy jewelry from
Kmart yeah word of advice Ian breath
printing out fake price tags that read
Tiffany's on it works just as well the
dragon story ain't bad either
this naturally gets Carl mad and he
tells you in broth off hey no fucker
back off do you hear me
back off no not not for me from her no I
will not mind Rumpy for that one your
bra starts to feel bad that he's not
doing his master proud so he decides to
throw him a party thinking it a win him
over
I wonder ah nothing but that strong
muscular kind of doughy design that most
videogame characters have what do you
think in broth can benchpress 1 maybe 2
pounds at most the rest of you get out
Carl of course ends everybody home but
just before finding out that your bra's
been given an upper management position
at his job but to be fair who can say no
to that 11:30 shadow it depends on
Jessica decides to leave - after she
discovers that Carl's been trying to
recreate her in the game customize your
character however you want then you
should be honored you know why cuz I'm
playing you in the game no Carl you're
playing me in real life honey honey we
will return to the Lifetime movie that
we stole from the Oxygen Network after
this what am I supposed to do rola or go
pound your pixelated pussy for all I
care haven't you seen the movie her it's
convincing and beautiful if you watch a
drunk
you brought decides to follow her lead
as he gives Carl one last farewell how
has it come to pass that you've become
bored with simply being you ruined my
life
now I lift it so you see kids Carl ends
up not getting what he wants because he
was a jerk to everybody oh I'm sorry I
just thought I'd point that out in case
you didn't catch what the subtle message
they were trying to put in there was
that Carl didn't get what he wanted
because he was a jerk everybody did you
get that did you get the message that
Carl didn't get what he wanted because
he was a jerk to everybody good because
it was a quiet not so in-your-face
message I'm afraid some of you might
have missed that Carl didn't get what he
wanted because he was a jerk to
everybody
oh it also wasn't analogy to the
Holocaust in there but everybody could
pick up on that
frustrated Carl makes yet another
foolish wish which gets him sucked into
the game as the female character he
created boy the zipi wishing logic
behind this is kind of sporadic isn't it
you have a duty I have a knife so so Ian
Roth lives his life to the fullest Carl
is trapped forever in his punishment and
a valuable lesson about obsessed gamers
is learned unless of course you're an
obsessed gamer in which case you have
seen the most noble humble funeral for
one of gaming's greatest heroes since I
don't know one of those doofuses who
played Warcraft to death or something
but that's only one of those stories we
have another one on the way everyone has
something they can't imagine after high
jinks child's doll can be equal to the
loss of a king's crown
I lost my doll once told me in love me
it's the only thing that ever told me it
loved me my god I miss you mister
Popples I'm glad you're mr. Pauwels did
that that mine just cut me with glass
and call me ethnic slurs probably show
had that looked at actually the next one
is called dragged in and already just as
credits has surpassed the plausibility
of the last story we saw but that's
where it pretty much stops as we see a
vet is abducted by two government agents
or maybe pallbearers I don't know for
what I want a person in black suit and
shades not to be a government agent and
is taken to a big dark room where I
think those guys who control the
Avengers make their decisions
three days ago we received the first
confirmed communication from beyond our
solar system radio astronomers have
traced the transmission to a planet 27
light-years away from Earth ah yes
because these guys look like the
pencil-pusher stiffs running our country
I'm sure this person especially has had
to keep a lot of top secrets about the
next friendship is Magic episode they
let him know that aliens from the planet
left over 60 Star Trek props is looking
for something from Earth but the video
is all jumbled so they want him to
translate what the aliens want something
you'll notice very quickly by the way is
that the special enjoys using wipes more
than newborn baby with a vomitus
allergic reaction to air look I can use
a wipe too and another one I'll Kevin
there so he translates the message and
it looks like the aliens won all the
world's cats why so that all the channel
awesome producers who have cats can make
cameos of course I really I miss that
fast there I found a replacement cat I
don't need him I woke up this morning
and my cats were were right here look
look there's the guest there's big Lloyd
I'll give a special one thing it's a
great ad why to get dogs speaking of
which the aliens that took all the cats
find I can't stand the cats why well
because they're cats lately that's the
last of them who would have known Oh
difficult it would be to hurt these
creatures ah so that's what dr. claw was
like all this time come to think of it
now the name kind of makes sense too
so they returned all the cast to earth
and then it just ends great story huh
I hear they had another story about King
Kong getting ready to rip up a city to
look for a bologna sandwich but then he
finds out he already had a bologna
sandwich and then he did nothing but
that was too exciting the next one is
called the reviewers start as well you
think your steaks ah that's more high
jinks by the way I talked to Vanessa
who the station manager want to see a
magic trick it's called fast forwarding
the filler it may not seem like much of
a trade but by god the feeling of joy
gives me sure seems magical there were
viewers this one centers around the
subject of the web critic looking to get
famous despite the fact that he has
basically nothing going for so pretty
much most web critics most we see our
main character trying to get noticed as
an online reviewer by dressing up as a
vampire and creating a gimmick anyway I
read an article one time about people
who do this kind of thing for a living
ha now I know this is fake nobody's ever
written an article about online
reviewing that require the online
demographic to read there what's this
it's chapstick for when you kiss my ass
after you see my video his best friend
comes over who is also interested in
this line of so-called work imagines to
make a video himself you refuse to watch
a Kissinger movie because I had Ron
silver beardless in it okay that was
literally him betraying his words and
that's something I got a problem with
you know it's brave that the special
tells a story about people making
productions with no money put into it at
all
by having it made by people making a
production with no money put into it at
all I'm like that David in the dentist
video did you know that was entirely
green screen and David was a CG puppet
in fact half the video was just a
rendering glitch his friend's video is
not big on cause either or even much for
viewing as long he does is tell giant
sci-fi stories that have nothing to do
with what he's actually talking about
while we're waiting for the rescue ship
to show up let's talk about Jason goes
to health the final Friday well that's
something I know reviewers constantly
don't do lose focus like the time I saw
Vin Diesel at the premiere of red 3
neither of us would
why we were actually there but you might
have noticed an edit there because I got
distracted by something that has nothing
to do with what we're talking about my
apologies now let us return to our
review wicker man - I was really ghost
right of you might have noticed another
edit there but that happens when you
have years of sexual repression building
up and then all you can think about
Jessica Lange dressed up as a snowman
with her big you might have noticed
another edit now I'm just gonna stop
there so these are the videos are giving
many hits but to his best friend that's
what matters least the most important
thing to know how you hit the big time
is if you have haters there's one
surefire way to see if the right people
are watching what's that it's if we have
any haters yet well if that's the case
Mel Gibson's career must be going
through the roof they also look to be as
popular as the number one personality on
YouTube called the Messiah hush hush I
thought I heard you calling my name now
hush and now we're reading from the
Association every time I think I'm the
only one who's lonely someone calls on
me and then along comes Mary dude this
empty cup is as sweet as the fudge okay
for once in my life I'm actually gonna
give the internet more credit and say
this would not be number one on YouTube
for one there's no cute animals racial
slurs or popular musicians dress like
prostitutes second even if it is said
tired
nothing religious on YouTube will ever
get anything past 90 views
I know because those 90 people all go to
the same church to ask why nobody
watches their sermons on YouTube so Andy
loses his job and he talks it over with
his friend and girlfriend who are now
seeing and apparently they're all
roommates
hey two-thirds in isn't the worst time
to establish your environment we all
live in this house together and I cannot
carry all three of our asses for another
month
hey I have a job I appreciate every
little thing you do but without Andy's
help I can find another job but it's
okay because they've gone into quadruple
digits because they've gotten a negative
response video from this guy's wearing a
shitty store-bought vampire costume that
makes them look like Bela Lugosi's
retarded faggot steps on the amazing
Stephen Dorff this is just constructive
criticism guys
so you can't get mad at me because if
you get mad at me you hate criticism and
that defeats the purpose fucking faggots
sounds like Tuesday's fan mail for me
what's the fun of making fun of things
if people also can't make fun of us but
they try to be optimistic as Andy wraps
up his thoughts on going into review
maybe we're not gonna be successful
right off the bat but I have to keep
trying as the Messiah once said I'm just
a soul whose intentions are good oh lord
please don't let me be this understood
you know we always called each other
good families like you tell someone yeah
you're gonna like this guy he's all
right he's a good fella
unless he's a reviewer in which case
you'd kick him in the nads and piss on
his aching scumbag body the reviewers so
as the reviewers wraps up we begin our
next special internet dating and me I
know you can program the first hi Jase
Cabot this one centers around my Jay
making a documentary of sorts showing
his attends as an internet personality
to try and get dates you know I've got
legions of fans who will throw
themselves at me literally once that was
messy and if you're like me all you can
think of when you see a funny British
person and the documentary is these go
to 11 he tries talking via Skype with a
date but finds a demon a hug who if you
don't know looks like Rama MacDonald if
he was melting into the Joker and he
tries to back out you
yeah I'm fine it's good to see you is it
yeah it is how you been
yeah no bad I'm really sorry my phone's
ringing
um it's my dentist um I'm left call you
back I'm really sorry bye yeah that's
gotta be tough to go through I wouldn't
be surprised if this veers are off men
and gears are towards women he finally
finds someone who seems to be up his
alley so he agrees to meet with her
it's raining in Britain what are the
fucking odds oh hey he must have driven
to a sunnier place like Seattle but
little does he realize he's not gonna
get what he expected as we see film
brain bravely playing the part of a
young bisexual woman you know I mean
that's just film brain playing film
brain
sorry film brain your name on the dating
website was mesh as in Michelle they
both get confused because their names
were jumbled online and apparently the
dating site had no place to identify
gender apparently ha how often does that
happen
I remember this one time it did online
dating and it turns out it was apparent
maybe to figure out how she could type
so Eminem decide to still continue the
date despite the fact that they have no
intention of being romantic at least in
this version the slash fig this would
spawn I can't speak for but they do come
on you've seen those drawings people
have done online you probably saw those
who thought mmm so I set up this date
with you so that I could kiss you maybe
just waiting for you to fall into
unconsciousness so I can learn across
the table have my dirty way so if you
like to see two guys arguing like a gay
couple without actually having sex then
clearly you need to see to believe Lee
eventually Mike drugs film brains drink
drags him off and that's it another very
quick Ginsburg story you know that King
Kong sandwich story something better and
better the more I think about it
so after we get our final special called
outside of the Internet
you mean there was a bright side to the
Internet this is another documentary but
not like the last one this is for lack
of a better term real no I do there is
no better term bell's the best one this
one's put together by Matt Williams aka
well she and aside from sounding like an
80s infomercial it starts off pretty
solid the days of high street shops with
DVDs and GameSpot over the counter seem
to be fading into a
garetty though it does sort of look like
the symbols from the men's and ladies
room somehow got their own sitcom
bathrooms from the people still
apologizing for gaben where there's a
positive there is always a negative and
the Internet is no exception
this is just a sample of the negatives
that the Internet can hold this is the
dark side of the internet not to be
confused with the wall of the Internet
or the division Bell of the Internet
while the positives of the Internet can
be viewed as beneficial to both us and
society in general there are just as
many negatives that are not only viewed
as a detriment to society but can paint
human beings in a harsh distinctly
negative light these can range from
copyright infringement to bullying
harassment stalking verbal abuse mental
abuse the list can go on and on yes
because there was no signs of that
before the Internet few people know that
Mussolini was secretly on tumblr
carrying a scenario to a real-life
situation oh look it's the missing
French leader of the Three Stooges
anorexia by the sheer fact that they
don't agree with you is seen as an
insult against you your character and
your beliefs so we hear about all the
various dangers of the Internet
including anonymity and how it can be
used to bully be a perverted predator
and just all-round be a loser dish what
are the consequences when the victim
gets threats directed to their email
their Facebook page or even their home
address I guess that's something that
experienced firsthand people have
anonymity and so they say things to you
that they wouldn't say in person they
have a mask to hide behind and
unfortunately when you're in the
spotlight when you are a personality who
has put themselves forward people know
you better than you know them and that
also makes you a target okay kind of
having a hard time finding anything
funny about this one um oh I know how
about the people being offended are just
whiny pansies and the actual bullies
themselves are just big losers what
about when the person is an older man or
woman preying on a younger male or
female using anonymity to seek out their
target and then slip away after
poisoning their mind and to believe in
what happened was their fault leaving
them free to move on to their next
target well when you put it like that
not everyone can read a comment and
laugh it off and no one in life is
flawless and perfect uh can we go back
to the lowbrow in his jokes please it
was kind of easier to say those weren't
funny than having my balls depressed off
people are individual oh my girl here we
go I do a brilliant car impression yeah
people always make fun of my boys new
words are important words have power and
are the basis by which human beings
interact with each other communication
speech uh uh writing words are
everything and as a writer I I Tate I
always take that to heart yeah okay so
what he says actually makes a lot of
sense
in fact what a lot of these people say
actually makes a whole shit ton of sense
putting fingers to ears because you
don't want to hear it isn't enough
because it's happening it's happening
right now while you're watching this and
instead of looking to blame society
video games the government or the TV
shows we watch stop looking to others
for the problem and look at yourself hey
hey hey as an American I take great
offense at that we as Americans always
have the right to blame something else
it is our gift of dodging responsibility
this vegetable saying if we want
something fixed we need to start with
the mirror well fine
I can fix you I can't fix you no no I
can't I can't I can't fix you you are
not too late you can be redeemed you are
fixable
you are fixable
and I'm gonna start now yeah now I
didn't hang that so much easier by God
we're right fixing the mirror did help a
lot
oh and looking into the deepest darkest
part of my soul and realizing I'm okay
I'm a human being and that everybody
goes to the things that I go through and
we can all heal and make the world
better also plays a big part but the
mirror I think works better okay so
maybe the special is pretty flawless it
does well showing those who may not
understand why hateful comments and
trolling and cyberbullying aren't just
something to be ignored and then in the
end also shows the value of appreciating
other people's work yeah I know what
this is getting to the uncanny valley
isn't perfect but it at least showcases
a lot of talented people doing their
thing and doing it to the best of their
ability and having a lot of fun doing it
there's a lot of talent a lot of
creativity and a lot of hard work that
went into this it's good people making
not classics but something that others
can look at and find enjoying it and in
the end why would I ever wanted to mean
something as beautiful as that
unless you paid a lot of money for me to
do so what you did the special socks and
the Nostalgia Critic I remember so you
don't have to
yeah